من خلال قوارب الصيد الباهتة في كولومبيا ،
بحث سمير جابلون عن
مكان ذلك القارب الذي سألت
هل أعادوه إلى البحر ،
ترتدي سامية صورة فيردي على قميصها
، وما زالت ترى ابنها في أحلامها ،
هذا القارب الذي يأخذ ابني
أنا أكره هذه الصورة أنا أكرهها.  أكرهها
لأنهم أخذوا ابني
في هذا الفيديو ، يمكنك أن ترى إيطاليا من
بعيد ،
إنها آخر صورة لسامية لفادي قبل
أن يختفي
في أوروبا ، يتم توفير الملايين من
الأوكرانيين المأوى من الحرب ولكننا في
تونس نتتبع ما هو غير
التونسي والتونسي.  يصف المسؤولون أكبر
موجة من المهاجرين غير الشرعيين منذ سنوات من
جميع أنحاء القارة الأفريقية ، يقوم المهاجرون
برحلة يائسة عبر
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​من خلال شبكة فضفاضة من
العصابات الإجرامية الخطيرة ، لذلك
سيتحدث منتجنا فقط إلى
زعيم التهريب الذي يعمل على محاولة الحصول على
الناس  خارج تونس إلى أوروبا ،
نرى فقط ما إذا كان مرتاحًا للتحدث
في هذا الحي
ولكن هذه منطقته ، فهؤلاء هم شعبه
الذي يقول إن عصابته تسحبهم  ما يصل إلى 20000
دولار أمريكي لقارب من المهاجرين يصل
إلى ألفي دولار لكل منهم
يعيش أو يموت ،
لا توجد ضمانات في البحر كما يقول
لأننا يمكن أن نأخذك لكن
السلطات يمكن أن تمسك بك
ما لم تموت ، فالموت
هو مصيرك  مثل هذا
الممر المكدس في السفن التي تغادر ليلاً ، هذا الممر هو أخطر
طريق هجرة معروف على كوكب الأرض يقول إن الأمم المتحدة
أكثر من 24000 في
عداد المفقودين منذ عام 2014 ، لكنهم لا يزالون يذهبون
في المرة القادمة التي آخذ فيها زوجتي
وابنتي ، كما يقول أحد المهربين على الرغم من  أنت
تعرف أن بعض الأشخاص لا يفعلون ذلك ،
نعم سيكونون في يد الله ما
يريده الله لنا ،
وغالبًا ما لا تتم هذه الصلوات دون إجابة.
إلى إيطاليا ،
حسناً ، تخيل
أن لدينا 10 10 أشخاص على متن
هذه القوارب الصغيرة في رحلة
120 ميلاً و 100 و 120 ميلاً ، لذلك في
بعض الأحيان تصبح عملية البحث عن
المهاجرين عملية
مساعدة  استعادة جثث الموتى
حتى مع أحدث المعدات الممولة من
الاتحاد الأوروبي والعقيد الأمريكي أيمن
مباكي يقول إن خفر السواحل لا يمكن أن
يتعقب آلاف المهاجرين الذين
يحاولون المغادرة
عندما يمسكون بهم ، ويقول
إنهم في كثير من الأحيان يقولون إنهم سيحاولون مرة أخرى
لا  بغض النظر عن مدى جودة تدريبك
وتجهيزك إذا لم تعالج
الأسباب الاقتصادية والاجتماعية للهجرة غير الشرعية
، فستستمر بالنسبة
للتونسيين والأفارقة الآخرين ،
لذلك نجعل هذه المجموعة من العاجيين
يأتون إلى هذا المكان بالقرب من البحر
ليس فقط هو  هذه
الرحلة المحفوفة بالمخاطر إلى أوروبا ، لكنهم خائفون
أثناء وجودهم هنا
على الشواطئ التونسية ،
فهم يعيشون حياة هامشية يعملون
لسنوات لمجرد توفير ما يكفي من المال
لدفع أموال للمهربين في كثير من الأحيان كعمال وخادمات
هنا في تونس ، إنه أمر سيء لأننا نعيش
بشكل غير قانوني.  ديبورا التي تريد اصطحاب
ابنتها البالغة من العمر أربعة أشهر على
متن قارب للمهربين عندما نصل إلى أوروبا ،
سنكون غير قانونيين أيضًا ولكن
الظروف أفضل ليس لدينا الحرية لها
هل أنت خائف من هذا التغيير في
كثير من الأحيان أنا خائف ولكن في بعض الأحيان لست كذلك
لأنني عندما أرى المشاكل التي أواجهها
تقول عندما أرى
مستقبلنا في أحلامي تتلاشى مخاوفي
تقول إن الأوكرانيين مرحب بهم لأنهم
هم أوروبيون يقود الاتحاد الأوروبي ملايين الأوكرانيين ،
فلماذا لا
يسمحون لمزيد من الأفارقة بالدخول إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي
[موسيقى]
محاطة بصورة ابنها
سمير تقول إن مهاجرًا واحدًا على الأقل على
متن قارب التهريب وصل إلى إيطاليا ، كما
قالا  لقد سبحها فادي أيضًا ثم
اختفى مثل الآلاف من قبله
ولكن هل ما زلت تأمل أن يكون على قيد الحياة
نعم بالطبع
نعمنعم
أنا أعاني كل يوم عندما
أنظر إلى صوره أنا أقاتل
وآمل أن
يساعده الله
ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن إن تونس